hey what's up welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artist react
we are looking at some cool mindbending
film making techniques today
wa how how I have a special special
discovery for these guys you know the
prism the Disney Soul Shard that holds
within it the magic to separate an image
from the background there's a new
technology that came out in the late '
80s that does the magic that that prism
did except you can see everything in
camera
what that's incredible also we're going
to be taking a look at a clip that a lot
of people have sent me because
everyone's wanting to dunk on it and it
is
hilarious what were they
thinking but I want to add some context
to it and look we've talked a lot about
like Star Wars and isand but there's
something that we usually skip over and
that is the amazing spaceships in Star
Trek there's one thing that's going to
blow your mind that I have to touch upon
and it's an incredible ingenious move on
how they actually film them there's a
lot of hype in this intro because this
is a good episode so let's let's just
jump
[Music]
in I think we should take a look at this
first movie called prom packed Disney
plus oh boy no I'm nervous PR I'm
nervous I'm
nervous what scares me about these clips
is why would a film like this ever need
visual
effects oh I see it I can't believe you
saw it already though I'm so
jealous I can't wait to find out what is
going on here ready Sam just look at the
crowd the
crowd that's it there's all there's one
row of janky CG monel that's it people
[Applause]
got it's funnier when they move they
were like oh no we need to put some
people in and they put some metahumans
and that girl
clapping oh my God so people kept
sending this to
me
what the freak is going on why would you
do
that what were they
thinking this is like my favorite thing
in the world it's like it's just like
why why why why why they literally the
animation
glitches it's just like a one frame like
it
snaps so what we're seeing here is it
looks like maybe just three Digi doubles
added into the crowd of people there no
there's four at least maybe even five
see those like random heads in the
background look at those characters like
what are they doing oh my gosh it might
be C
actually we found some
more what I find so bizarre about this
is that like I don't understand why
there's obviously plenty of extras I
don't know why either look at all the
extras on several row up they could have
just been sitting there they literally
could have just rodo some people in like
the foreground ear and just tast in them
or something with some different timing
there's so many things they could have
done but this is like the best this is
the best best way to do
it it's also just so bizarre to me
because it took so much work and effort
to do that one little shot cuz you have
to rotoscope all of the people in the
foreground you have to actually animate
and render out the characters that you
make and then you get them all situated
you get the lighting matching and then
you have to composite it in that's a lot
of work just for this one second shot
when you could just been like hey you
four people in the back can you come sit
up front I think what happened here is
that they got the shot and they didn't
notice until they're in the edit and
they're like there's something going on
here that we have to like hide cuz had
they realized whatever it was in the
moment any producer any director would
have been like yeah get those extras and
put them there yeah it's it's harder to
put a CG person in a spot than it is
just put a person in a spot but what was
there it's like a dark
secret tremendous amount of work just
for something so short that and
completely unnecessary if they would
have just added like some facial
expression onto the characters the shot
probably would have worked and we no one
would have noticed cuz you look at it
and it's it's like the lighting's good
the rendering is actually pretty good
the comp's good the Roto is good like
actually yeah the one thing is just how
they're
like this is this is a 3:00 a.m. I want
to go home and go to sleep I'm going to
pop up an Unreal Engine and drop a
metahuman in like that's what happened
here they almost got away with it they
Almost Got Away With It it weren't for
you meddling kids I'm just saying
without those guys without those CG guys
in the shot we wouldn't be watching this
movie but look they're there and now
they have a new audience
us so we like we haven't watched this
movie or really any of these kind of
films are there any like really weird
VFX shots in these kind of movies that
you know of uh please leave a comment so
we can check them out in the future okay
we've seen a lot of janky effects movies
are flopping all over these days and
money is just getting thrown all over
the place Hollywood needs to get a grip
on their budgets and if it's true for
Hollywood it's true for your personal
life that's that's why I'm here to
introduce today's sponsor rocket money
rocket money is an all-in-one Finance
platform that helps you save more and
spend less it's a personal finance app
that allows you to manage subscriptions
lower bills build a custom budget and
grow your savings all in one easy to
used platform so I'm actually super
excited I am going to the Philippines
this year I get to go spend the holidays
with my family in the tropical Paradise
but an international trip to Asia isn't
exactly the cheapest thing you have to
save and you have to budget I here to
tell you how rocket money has helped me
do that one of them is canceling
unwanted subscriptions rocket money can
identify reoccurring subscriptions and
then if you're just looking at that list
and you're like I don't really need to
be paying that Netflix subscription
anymore you don't even have to go to
Netflix right within rocket money they
will help you cancel your account rocket
money's also helped me lower my bills I
have serus XM in my car and they were
able to renegotiate my yearly premium
and actually saved me $8 per month it's
pretty sweet it also helps you monitor
your credit score you get free credit
score checks it also lets you know if
you have any impact items that are
affecting your credit score so you can
work towards paying those off and
getting your credit score back on track
one of the features I really like is the
net worth calculator basically attach
all your bank accounts and also attach
all your credit cards and debts and
it'll give you a balance of what your
total net worth is seeing it all in one
place is really helpful to get you back
in that positive or just work to grow
your total net worth so if you want to
save more and spend less and join the
user base of 5 million people go to
Rocket money.com crew or just hit that
link at the top of the description and
you can get started for free I also
highly recommend you unlock some of
those premium features as they've been
super helpful for me but with that let's
get into some really old school
Hollywood effects it's not too often
that you discover a technological Marvel
on the show that that I I've never heard
of there's a new technology that came
out in the late 80s not only did it let
you do crazy background replacement it
also let you put something in the
foreground in front of the actor and it
let you do all of this in camera wait
hold up it's called intovision it was
used for The Fugitive it was used for
standby me it was used for Rambo 3 the
fugitive that's actually a relatively
recent movie when it comes to old old
movies
I'm going to show you a scene here and
you tell me how did they do the visual
effects oh whoa hold up hold up he's not
even on a bus he's completely not in the
shot at all but the but is it's but
those the motion blur edges motion blur
the motion blur edges it's impossible to
composit
[Music]
that um um wait a minute yeah doing a
train how do you do these shots well
considering the fugitive came out a
while ago digitally comping Two Shots
together wasn't exactly an option I'm
seeing what looks like two completely
different shots we had the foreground
bottom there that Harrison Ford is
standing on including him and the bridge
but behind him we have the trees that
little building those lamps and the
train and the dust cloud in front of the
train but yeah then the train gets very
close to camera in fact the train I
think even goes off the ledge there how
do you combine this in an age before
digital compos
yeah cuz that soft edge of that dirt
right there is impossible to chemically
blue screen or green screen impossible
though what about the magic Soul Shard
that's right there was one technique if
you ever saw the react episode to Mary
Poppins we talk all about the magic
Crystal the soul gem the soul gam of
Walt Disney so that brought about a
magic ability to perfectly composite
people onto a background green screens
before green screens were a thing it was
actually used quite a lot until it was
lost to the sands of time
there was another team that came up with
something perhaps even better would you
guys like to know how this was done was
there another type of prism so
everything you're seeing here is in
camera there is no compositing happening
this is all in you you look through the
eye piece this is what you see that's
crazy it's crazy it's absolutely insane
how how why how come there's no oh green
screen VFX so you might be saying well
Nico it's really obvious how they did
this it's just rear projection no it's
not rear projection because the exposure
on the background is Flawless yeah if it
was rear projection you're talking about
degradation yeah rear projection is kind
of like photocopying a photocopy you can
always tell like anytime you see like
James Bond driving you see like this
weird background and it's like totally
separate even when it's done really
really well like in 2001 Space Odyssey
with the monkeys at the beginning it's
like you can still kind of tell but like
the quality is Flawless across the
screen here this feels like the volume
from the mandalorean doesn't it and this
is effectively the grand papy of that
technology all right we're stumped okay
so like at the very least it's two
separate things that were filmed at two
separate times being combined I'll give
you a hint Scotch light Scotch light
reflective
fabric it's retrolective material so it
reflects light exactly back to where it
came from stop signs and whatnot they
reflect light really well back to the
source of that light but not really very
well bouncing it in any other direction
so if you combine that with some sort of
prism that can split light beams somehow
like like a beam
splitter a projector and a beam splitter
and a scotch light screen so okay this
is kind of like rear projection not rear
projection rear projection is when the
projector would be behind the screen and
you'd see the image through the screen
front projections when the projector's
in front of the screen like a normal
movie screen right so I guess
technically this is closer to front
projection if it was just front
projection from the camera's perspective
how do you project from a camera's
perspective Sam you put a camera
projector next to your camera then
they're not lined up you need to line it
up to get your full reflection it's
retrolective I think I have it figured
out basically they have the camera
filming normally through a mirror out of
45° angle a one-way mirror it's a
projector projecting off of that mirror
out into the background but then you'd
still get that projection on Harrison
Ford in the foreground but unless it's
too dim and the only way to get that
reflection back is to have something
incredibly reflective retrolective
retrolective background that's then
going back to the camera lens and is
able to pick it all up I'm just
incredibly impressed that it can
actually do that you got to figure it
out so it's only when you line up
exactly with the light beams from the
projector which would be impossible
without a 45° piece of glass the image
appears just like how your headlights
light up a street sign who no way is
that crazy no way that's so cool what
yeah it's so crazy like what a cool
piece of tech and it got used all the
time what I have never thought about
this
before that's incredible but here's the
crazy thing it wasn't just backgrounds
they also can do foregrounds in motion
as well so you can have a person in
between a foreground and a background
cuz that's probably how they did
Harrison Ford jumping off the bus cuz he
had to be standing on something but we
can't see that something this looks so
good yeah it obviously works really well
there there's nothing more I hate seeing
than like matte lines those gross black
GB edges it's so distracting and this is
like that perfect Middle Ground where I
I like I can't believe I've seen this
stuff so many times before and never
knew how it was
made wait wait what
so Army of Darkness was actually filmed
a lot with introvision it's used in like
60% of the shots you can actually see it
in action here with the tiny little
Bruce Campbell's running around using
the intervision process we're able to
take uh photography plates of a
miniature or um stills of a miniature
and project them behind the actors and
in that way create the illusion that
they're in front of this castle without
actually having to pay for the large
scale construction of it so you
basically end up with a system that is
kind of like the oldfashioned version of
the volume from the man mandalorean
because you can have people act in front
of a moving background you can direct it
in the moment you can have a moving
camera you can even have things in the
foreground this still requires the same
sort of philosophy that led stages
require today it requires you to have
the stuff you want to put up on the wall
ready to go ahead of time the reason why
people started moving to green screens
is cuz they didn't have to know that
stuff in the moment you can get your
shot and then figure out what the
background is going to be later you're
right r at the end of the day this
requires you to be prepared before your
shoot with all your background assets
which is a lot hard said than done it
yeah people are like yeah just like do
that first it's order of operations
right and it's like well you haven't
made a
movie you know what I'm not going to ask
you to subscribe today I'm just going to
ask you to maybe watch one other video
of ours today that will be the same
thing as
subscribing I'm actually dead serious
that's how that's true that's how the
algorithm
Works These Are the Voyages of the
Starship Enterprise I keep thinking
about Star Trek a lot Star Trek the Next
Generation was one of the most incredi
looking television shows to exist like
think about one show from the 80s that
you watch and go oh yeah that holds up
Star Trek I watched it a lot when I was
a kid I was like maybe four or five the
first time I saw this show and my
parents were watching it I'm just like
holy balls and somehow the show holds up
after 35 years it's crazy that Patrick
Stewart has looked the same since the
Next Generation exactly Patrick Stewart
still holds
up one thing that always gets me is the
dang little spaceships the dang little
spaceships looked arguably even better
than the liveaction
footage so check out these chips oh yeah
those are great do you see the Fidelity
yeah of what's going on there they look
like really nice 3D models right I mean
but they're just they're Real Models
they're real break this down in in your
eyes with your knowledge how do you
think they do this stuff so the thing
that's jumping out to me about these
shots is that like there's multiple
lights being emitted from the ship since
we know that this is motion control they
can do the same camera move over and
over again you can have like one where
it's the beauty P the ship it's nicely
lit another one where you turn off all
the lights but just have all the little
fiber optics pinging out light out out
of the ship's windows then maybe another
pass where all the lights coming out of
the thrusters and then you just expose
the film over and over again I mean
that's what they did on like Blade
Runner you're right it's definitely it's
a multi-pass situation you have a motion
control rig you'll notice one thing in
particular here the rear engine have
like a certain glow to them yeah do you
know how they're doing that I'm going to
guess they're putting a filter on the
camera and doing a new exposure getting
a nice fuzzy like lens effect you're
right putting that Haze that bloom
filter on the engine lights is such a
nice nice touch because it just makes
them feel a little extra brighter so
cool and you know what they they might
just be doing the lights with a black
light so I don't think the interior
lights that you're seeing are black
light but there are black lights being
used and I'm wondering if you can guess
where oh I know where it is it's for the
the green screen it's for the the
background yeah to make the background
glow yes so you get a perfect mat this
is an orange screen oh so okay so that
way they're getting a just a pure black
cut out of the ship because it really
doesn't show much of the black light but
the background gets really active and
energized in the black light and it
glows yes exactly so this is why I
wanted to talk about this because I
heard about so cool I'm so sad that this
like isn't a thing in visual effects
anymore so this orange screen it's not
just an orange piece of screen it's like
okay they're they're trying to get the
cleanest cutouts possible here and the
the solution they came up with for this
was to use a fluorescent orange backdrop
that's being lit with black lights and
what that does very specifically is it
makes it so the bounce and spill
happening from those lights on the
models isn't that same color cuz if you
look at the models you'll see when the
black lights are on they have a little
tinge of blue there see that and that
makes it so that there able to get a way
way way way cleaner mat for these ships
compared to what they did on Star Wars
where that background was just a classic
blue screen but then you end up with
that spill that blue light on the ships
uh and that totally blew my mind I also
just noticed the ships are being held up
by little glass tubes or it's painted
it's painted it's it's it's got the same
orange yeah it's painted with the same
paint dang okay that's how effect of
that is yeah it just looks like it's
see-through it's super even what but
then how are they doing this stars in
the background pretty straightforward
you know you have like black you know
painted plexiglass they scratch off
little holes for the light to come
through but when it comes to the camera
motion what they do is they actually
take all the translation coordinates off
the motion control rig and uh only use
the rotational ones oh so smart and so
now suddenly cuz yeah the stars are far
away so you don't want your camera push
doing a push up to the Stars they
basically retain almost all the same
same data that they use to film the ship
but yeah it just doesn't move in 3D
space now it's just rotating giving you
that like effect of the Stars being
really far away it effectively removes
Parallax because stars are so far away
it doesn't matter how far you move in a
local space those stars are not really
going to move in relation to you but if
you have a shot with like plexiglass
with holes in it and you're moving the
camera through those holes are going to
move through space in a way that stars
cannot do cuz there so there literally
light yours away
years away versus 10t away in the studio
that's so smart so let's just remove
parallx by not having the camera move
through space we'll just stay in one
spot but we'll get all the rotational
data still that's so smart also
plexiglass scratching off holes for
light to shine through I had no idea
that's Inus think about that either man
all this just just to put a picture on
or behind or in another picture look at
that that's all the entire this we've
made 100 and like what like 20 episodes
about people trying to put a picture in
another picture and make it look real
convincing all we're trying to do is
take two pictures and pretend like they
were taken at the same time that's all
we're trying to do I mean all we're
trying to do is look at the pictures
being put in pictures yeah and telling
you our feelings upon
them